okay so the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
about to close off phase 4 with the
release of wakanda forever later this
year the studio is unmatched in its
cohesiveness and though many have tried
to imitate it none have managed it even
the studio that's in second place still
hasn't come close to pulling off what
Kevin foggy has accomplished and so many
of them have struggled to even get out
the gate with their shared Universe
plans though it seems almost perfect in
design the original plan for the MCU was
a lot different and I thought we'd ask
what if Kevin feige had gone with his
original Vision throughout this video
we're gonna be going over what the
universe was originally meant to look
like the characters in it and also the
payoff that we would have got so come
with us Watcher as we break it all down
and discuss what was originally supposed
to happen if you enjoy the video please
hit the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe because I love your
3000 we also just launched Eclipse
Channel that's about to hit 2 000
subscribers and I'd really appreciate it
if you guys check that out I'll leave
that as the pin comment and with that
other way hi welcome to the heavy
spoilers show I'm your host Paul AKA
your friendly neighborhood spoiler man
now let's get into the breakdown
now in order to discuss the full plan we
have to talk about how hard up that
model were in the 90s as it massively
affects the way that things were laid
out Marvel Studios itself started up in
the same decade and it mainly worked
with licenses as part of its parent
company now Marvel Studios basically
centered around selling off major
characters to other Studios so that the
company could keep afloat I'm sure
you've heard the story about how they
had to sell office equipment to other
places just to keep the lights on and
they had truly fallen from greatness in
this time they sold the film rights to
Spider-Man the X-Men Fantastic Four Hulk
and all their Flagship characters Hulk
did sort of get a Cooperative deal with
universal but it was pretty much the
company trying to scramble for as much
cash as they could before it all came
crashing down in 1996 they filed for
bankruptcy but slowly they managed to
claw their way back at the time American
businessman Carl ican started buying
Bonds in the company at 20 of their
value and he eventually took over
everything in 1997 during the bankruptcy
renegotiation phase Thai is then bought
Marvel from the banks and shortly after
this it was once more taken over again
by Ron Perlman who regained control
again slowly it was pulled out of
bankruptcy and it would go on to become
the Juggernaut that we now knowed as
today now in 1998 the company got
somewhat of a Big Revival in the
mainstream with the release of blade
blade was a big gamble for them and
under the name Marvel Enterprises the
film released to positive reviews it
also got a box office of 131 million at
the back of a 45 million budget making
it not a massive success but still
really really positive now it wouldn't
be long before other Studios started to
propel the property purchases that
they'd bought and we saw the X-Men and
Spider-Man drop to great success it's
also got a lot of interest in the comics
and marble sales slowly but surely
started to pick up they got a lot of
secondary gains from selling this stuff
and the brand related income that came
in from merchandising offered them New
Opportunities Marvel Studios started
looking at self-financing in 2004 and
and they put together a plan to make 10
films this was going to span across an
8-year window while it's getting roughly
one a year but in some instances too
it's important to bear in mind that they
didn't own the rights to Iron Man at
this time and thus he's not included in
the original plan new line owned him up
to November 2005 and then when they were
released it vastly altered what Marvel
were gonna do what they wanted to create
though was the following a Captain
America movie that started it all off
and Nick Fury won Hawkeye power pack
shung Chi black panther Ant-Man Cloak
and Dagger and also an Avengers one and
the one that probably stands out the
most to you there is The Avengers who
would have had a completely different
lineup we don't know the specifics here
but Nick Fury would have followed the
same role that he did in the eventual
phase one that we got he'd go around
recruiting the other members of the team
and the Avengers themselves would be
made up of the characters I mentioned so
yes Xiang Chi and black panther were
originally going to be part of the team
along with Hawkeye and Captain America
this is also of course Dr Strange in
Ant-Man who did end up coming into the
MCU after Civil War and it shows how
much things changed once Marvel started
regaining their IPs out of the entire
lineup they had only Captain America and
the Avengers ended up actually being
released in their original eight years
showing how much stuff can shift about
now along with getting the Iron Man
rights back they also secured them from
other studios though was freedom from
Paramount Black Widow came from
Lionsgate and Hulk was freed up slightly
from Universal so you can't see how
getting this all back really started to
change things and interestingly Tony
Stark was never supposed to be the face
of the MCU it's weird to think about
this especially due to how iconic Robert
Downey genius betrayal is but he was
thought of as a character they could use
to introduce others rather than being
the main guy the position of power was
originally gonna fall to the Hulk who
Marvel had had success with due to Ang
Lee's movie and of course the legendary
70s TV show Robert Downey Jr wasn't even
really wanted to be part of the universe
at the time due to conduct Mercy
surrounding him and it was only due to
John Barrow that they were convinced to
take the shot his movie was a big
success and after Iron Man was released
Marvel announced that the other films
they had coming would all lead into the
Avengers slowly things started slot into
place with a shared Universe plan all
coming together bit by bit Tony appeared
in The Incredible Hulk though was hinted
at an Iron Man 2 and then Thor itself
ended with a tease to The Avengers with
Captain America showing the first
trailer for it now from this point
onwards Marvel came to realize how
important it was to have a plan in place
and they of course finished out the
Avengers with a tease towards Thanos in
the post-credits scene the studio also
started to Showcase their plans far in
advance so that they could make minor
changes to it if needs be Marvel
admitted that after Batman v Superman
was announced they decided to change
direction and having such a plan laid
out like this allowed them to be
reactive and see where Trends were going
there was also Spider-Man homecoming
that originally wasn't part of the
lineup but this all changed after the
Sony email hack the studio are heading
down The Amazing Spider-Man route but
they ended up talking it out with bikey
and the two sides came to a deal that
allowed him to come back into the
universe there's also the Inhumans that
were dropped after the series didn't go
down too well but on the whole Marvel
has been a big success they reached the
point now where they've almost got back
the rights to all their original
characters and going forward into phase
five and six we'll be seeing more from
the Fantastic Four and likely the X-Men
some of the standout things about the
original plan 2 are characters that we
never really got in the MCU though Cloak
and Dagger got a show we still haven't
heard anything about power pack and
they're probably the most obscure
characters on the entire list there's
also the Nick Fury movie which I think
we will sort of get when secret Invasion
rolls around looking back at what was
originally meant to be it's kinda crazy
to think how things have changed and it
shows the big comeback Journey that
Marvel have gone on here's an
organization that had to sell filing
cabinets to stay afloat they now
completely dominate the industry that we
don't know exactly what the plot of
these movies would have been it's
interesting to see how it all changed
and it really makes you wonder if what
we got is the best thing that we could
have got personally I think it is and
the big risk in Robert Downey Jr really
paid off as it allowed them to get
attention on their company during a time
when DC was dominating with its Dark
Knight trilogy it's really interesting
to see how stuff in the original plan
has now been drafted in but I'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on it
in the comments below we're in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness on the 15th of
August and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the plan if
you picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now so that's you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the original plan for Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness you go over
what Scott Derrickson wanted to do in
the film how it differs from what we got
with Remy and yeah it's really
interesting to see what could have
happened if not then thanks for sticking
to the video I've been Paul I'll see you
next time take care peace